we really had to push the limits of what
we could do serious injuries sneaky
parties on set bromances for the history
books stunts that left actors battered
and bruised uncharted had it all and
more we've got the inside look at all it
took to bring this movie to life
number one should we get these to a room
well the first time we met we hit it off
ten minutes into meeting each other tom
knew it was fate i realised if we got
the chance to work together we'd be fast
friends the bromance was real and made
the relationship on screen perfect the
thing that that elevates the material is
the chemistry between the two of us
while they loved each other they didn't
make their fair share of jabs we were
good mates and you know we there's a
good rivalry between the two of us which
was a lot of fun and that rivalry made
it out to the green you know we hung out
quite a lot outside of work we were
playing golf with each other and having
dinners we're lucky to have each other
as a kind of team
number two
unexpected is always welcome most of
what mark and i are saying to each other
is is an improv holland and wahlberg
were throwing lines in left right and
center you know we were constantly
uh you know testing each other wahlberg
doesn't miss a beat mark's just a really
naturally funny guy who brings all kinds
of lines oh and if tom weren't busy
enough flaring behind the bar he went
the extra mile with his bartenders savvy
wisecracks i mean there's lines
throughout where tom was
coming up with great moments
number three
whiskey sour please bartender tom the
actor's slick flare moves came from some
real life practice part of his prep work
for the role saw the actor behind the
bar at chilton firehouse slinging drinks
and flipping bottles like a pro number
four
with the bartender around why not i said
to the producers like can we keep the
bar open okay so keep this on the dl i
probably shouldn't say this because it's
very i guess it's kind of illegal but
that bar scene looked rowdy for a reason
i would basically say to crew members
like what would you like to drink who
says no that kind of offer i was really
making drinks and just slyly like giving
them to the crew they were filming on a
friday night and when they wrapped for
the day tom wanted to keep the party
going and i was the bartender it was
amazing number five
this was the most terrifying stunt for
tom in the movie and it was awful the
giant set was built and then they would
drop it into the water and it would
sink and the stage was set for the
actors to hold their breath for an
insane amount of time all while trying
to swim out of a hole in the back of the
structure and up to the surface yep
definitely terrifying
number six
it's just so good and guess what it only
took a casual five weeks to film yikes
it's the hardest action sequence i've
ever made shooting so much practically
meant holland was hanging a hundred feet
in the air at one point barely attached
to a spinning block and it was really
scary oh and then he goes tumbling
through the sky i was shooting stunts
that are far bigger than anything i've
done before and these were all just for
one sequence
number seven
the one that sends tom flying and then
the car would sort of zoom towards me i
would hit it and then fly off and it was
oh so effective but it made holland's
job tricky the hardest thing was is
ruben really wanted me to try and stay
horizontal as i left the airplane before
i went into my sort of spin nailing this
took a whopping 17 takes so it took a
long time to get right and it just so
happened that that was the day that my
mum came to watch she wasn't a fan of
seeing her boy get so battered my mum's
sort of coming up to me on like the 12th
take like do you not think they've got
it already can't they move on who can
blame her
number eight
there were some weird faces captured i'd
be sort of coming into land and i'm like
holland who's been used to donning his
spidey suit or relying on cgi to mask
the faces that he makes while going
through his insane stunts my stun
doubles would come up to me and be like
tom that was great but less face mate
just speaking was hard enough in the
middle of all the action it's really
difficult to sound normal because
normally you're like yeah really so it
can be it can be tough number nine
teeth were nearly lost
seriously mark actually hit me in the
teeth
with a sword it happened the way that
sword fighting accidents happen and as
he did his backswing he like clipped me
in the teeth no wonder tom swore he'd
never film a sword fight scene again
can't risk losing those pearly whites
number 10. his teeth were salvaged but
his body was not it was more physically
demanding taking all those hits and
landings left a mark you know i got
bangs and bruises here and there one of
the riskier stunts that he did himself
didn't take quite the toll i did quite a
gnarly like jump over a railing in in
barcelona my whole right side was like
black and blue and when he was nearly at
the finish line i got really bad
tendinitis in my hamstring things got
even tougher which isn't a very cool
injury that's just from overwork number
11
tom's typical days on set were far from
easy
in just one day holland whipped out a
backflip over his co-star wahlberg
and then he duked it out with two even
buffer stunt legends but that's not all
there was talk of a potential stunt
involving a 50-foot drop and being
caught by a chandelier for real dude
earns his paycheck
number 12.
does time-off even exist
tom has been busy starring in well
everything and at one point the actor
was near total burnout near the end of
filming while struggling with rough
tendinitis holland had to call it asking
for a weekend to rest and just heal the
production totally understood they've
got to take care of their star number
13.
it's tough to be this cool one of the
hardest parts of becoming nathan drake
was funnily enough settling into the
cool dude vibes tom has pulled off the
not so smooth peter parker but this was
a new ball game and one that the actor
was very ready for when he went back to
the no way home set he actually had to
de-qualify number 14. and sometimes
looking cool is a downfall holland knew
he had to look slick but at times he
took it a bit too far i think there are
elements of my performance in uncharted
where i kind of fell under the spell of
being i want to look good now i want
this to be my cool moment luckily his
acting shops make up for a few moments
of vanity
number 15
epic playlist music anyone there are two
moments in the movie where we feature
the uncharted score as a nod to fans
ramin jawadi who was responsible for the
game of thrones score worked his magic
for uncharted he did our entire original
score specific to the film creating
original themes for nathan drake while
the score of the original game is epic i
wanted to make sure that our movie stood
alone from the game and that we weren't
just recreating it for fan
number 16. he's a real tough guy
wahlberg got to work achieving
incredible physical shape for filming
training included loads of cardio weight
lifting functional movement and of
course the perfect push-up
number 17 the pressure was on i realized
that i looked like mark's like 12 year
old son
an unexpected five-month break was great
for tom because he got to try and catch
up to wahlberg's level of buff all i did
was eat and train every day protein
shakes protein shakes all the time it
was a nightmare but it was all worth it
just for a compliment from his buddy
mark he did actually comment and was
like wow you've put on some serious size
so i was i was actually really grateful
for the break number 18. he's a sony boy
living in a sony world and i remember
thinking at the time like wow this would
make an incredible movie how exactly did
tom get involved with this project well
it all began while filming a little
movie called spider-man homecoming
spider-man 1 and obviously spider-man
being a sony movie and sony owning
playstation one of the luxuries is you
always get a playstation in your trailer
and you know he played uncharted tom was
hooked you know i was a massive fan of
this game so it was a huge honor to sort
of bring him to life and develop the
character number 19.
this movie was a long time coming and
over the span of about a decade seven
different directors were attached at
some point or other we're talking about
some big names
davido russell travis knight seth gordon
dan tratchenberg and neil berger the
search was stressful but ruben fleischer
eventually got the gig which was a
relief to everyone involved
number 20 ready set
and wait tom holland showed up to set
raring to go only to be turned away as
the team shut down production
indefinitely because of covid once they
were all back antonio banderas had to
dip out for a month as he battled the
virus himself
a blockbuster like this is tough to
create but with this team around it's a
bit of a dream which part do you think
would have been most fun to film